For this question, you're asked to define a function, pick_one,
which takes as its input a Boolean and a Boolean can be the values True or False.
If the value of the Boolean is True, you're going to return the first input.
I'm going to call that true_response.
If the it's false, you return the second input--false_response.
I've named them like that so I don't forget which way around they are.
In order to define the procedure, I'll call the first variable boolean, with a lowercase b.
Don't forget the colon.
What we need is we need something that happens when the Boolean is true,
and if I do if boolean, then the code underneath this is executed when boolean is true.
In that case, I want to return true_response.
Otherwise, when the boolean is false, I want to return false_response.